einfach keinen sinn das ist schon
richtig 36 und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge hacker schon dass es
ein format in dem ich mir hacker
material des e mails schickt anschaue
und kommentiere sie zwei wege wie ihr
material zu schicken können für beide
ist es wichtig dass ihr das video als um
gelistetes video auf youtube hochladen
also euer material und mir den link denn
entweder per mail an hacker shootout
blog.de schickt die mailadresse ist auch
in der beschreibung verlinkt oder indem
er mich auf youtube eine private
nachricht schickt das geht indem ihr auf
meinen kanal geht dann noch keine info
und dann private nachricht schicken
lassen die zwei wege ich würde sagen wir
starten einfach mal direkt die erste 1
sendung kommt von fabi kraft das video
heißt hacker auf tirolia mega viele
hacks hat der drin caps okay schauen sie
einfach mal rein
so wie beim leistungsniveau des dahinten
andere richtung sich einfach hoch achtet
darauf
er hat sich deshalb wirklich dem
teleporter ausmacht eigentlich zu
schnell für den flyer oder das gemacht
man hier guck mal und dreizack es aber
da oben krass wie geht so was schreibt
man dass man die kommentare ist der neue
telefone oder wie übrigens leute eine
sache die ich noch anmerken möchte ich
behaupte nicht dass ich anno von hacks
habe ich bin absoluter laie in absoluter
lukas hacks angeht
das ist auch gar nicht schlimm die
scheibe einfach an was ihr mir
zugeschickt und kommentiere es aus der
sicht eines normalen minecraft spieler
keinen plan von hecken hat vergehen noch
becker darauf schauen wir einmal wie
dieser klassisches der vom heaven moment
wo er einfach so von oben herunter
fliegt hier für die leute aber
runterlaufen sagte akt aber macht gar
nicht kurzen prozess der hacker team
relativ gelassen pixel oder und
speedflyer heckhoff hielt kilo war alles
klar
da war wieder mal ein
dabei würde ich sagen okay die nächste
einstellung stammt von dac und das video
heißt hashtag ein skill auch okay mal
gucken was hier passiert ist das ist
aber kein klarer
das könnte noch legend seien gerade mal
ein komischer kopf regungslos longo war
oder doch ist es eine ist es neckar ich
weiß gar nicht am anfang sah es
eigentlich normal aus das macht er jetzt
okay okay das erz gabriel bisschen
komisch aus es stellt sich aber die
ganze an die wand macht nichts
ok
ich weiß nicht ich weiß nicht
seht ihr das da ist wirklich so ein
muster er läuft die ganze zeit weg
stellt sich mit dem rücken zu ihm und
gebt ihn dann immer so richtig krass
erhitzt okay das ist schon heftig aus
wahrscheinlich defekten screenshot
machen
er versteht aber nicht guck mal er
schaut hier oben so weg weil ein
speedcheck machen will
genau in dem moment jetzt gilt wieder
kämpfen okay der kopf ist schon
sehnsucht habe ich ein schwert ich kann
nur mit dieser wäscheklammer dienen okay
was war das alter das war richtig krass
aus jetzt zahlt aus der angel hat die
vier blöcke waren das sieben acht blöcke
okay der kopf ist eigentlich schon
richtig
was man dir schreibt meine kommentare ob
er glaubt dass ein hacker war oder nicht
nächsten sendung leute stammt von lets
flipper und sein video heißt dreister
geht es nicht punkt für dich sg
mittelpunkt matt walsh hacker also
scheinbar spielt sich das alles im bett
whatsup okay man sieht okay doch diesen
speed bilder auf jeden fall gibt es eine
antwort ist einfach gegner von ihm ja ok
ok sei halte wie schnell dass ich auch
hoch stecken sind hier sind einem team
oder nicht ist es wirklich gerade in
gegner und der versuch seine hexen sind
in einem team und er zeigt seine ex die
dokumente zwar keinen sehen dass wir
seit schon richtig 3 er springt
absichtlich runter und erotik zu werden
ich klicke hier seht ihr das wäre es mit
absicht macht einfach richtig dreist
warum machst du das immer wieder
oder ist gestorben erhält h es springt
einfach runter wird hochtief krieg
falsch halten und stirbt einfach und
verliert die runde die große frage ist
jetzt war das absicht von ihm oder war
wirklich so schlecht da sowohl die
meinem ziemlich langweilig befragt all
das macht einfach keinen sinn
mir war alles egal guck mal hier sind
ihm lila und einem chat stets es stirbt
teamleader fliegt raus und team rot
gewinnt die runde
eine starke nummer auf jeden fall ich
würde sagen eine einsendung können auch
einpacken
die hier stammt von minecraft vikings
sogar 1080p richtigen asiens und die
implementierung scheibe haben sie in
jump wollen hacker gesehen wir schon
rein und die geschichte ist jungs
dachten dass hier werde hektar wald im
chat geschrieben haben höhe hacker
reporter thema bitte dieser erde
aber er ist einfach kein hacker aber
passt jetzt mal auf seht ihr das es
schlägt einfach seine kiste liegt
einfach die ganze zeit die kiste uhr
jetzt geht's ab alles klar
ok
wie der klassische hacker schädel sie
haben ihn sogar noch gekillt hat noch
ein leben als jetzt packen den hacker
rauszuhauen usa wo ist da wo es sein und
der hacker hatte noch richtig gutes
equipment go go go go go jungs packen
oder um es da und hat einfach die ganze
zeit installiert die luft what the [ __ ]
es ist halt so offensichtlich und es
raus elser war direkt nein erkan respawn
läuft was das für ein typ mann
wir haben durch die luft pustet okay er
kann hat überhaupt nicht hätten die
kasse dem zweck wird ein leben nach sein
kollege ist rausgeflogen waren gegen
worden und ich lege für die ganze hätten
die luft ist so dumm so offensichtlich
älter jetzt kommt er kriegt jetzt das
war's das war es auf jeden fall raus
noch nicht noch nicht machen hielt noch
nicht das war's das was von hacker leute
die gibt es jeden sonntag also schaut wo
ich sonntags immer rein auf meinen kanal
da immer eine neue vorschau das gern man
sich gefallen hat wir sind vom nächsten
video video haut reinhold und ja